yeah i don't understand why you haven't
been
fired from that why you weren't fired i
don't understand how i still live with
him
yeah if you think the house smells weird
that's because he pisses on the balcony
well first of all we all are wondering
why you're
that it really isn't what i mean what
like baron holt says like i don't
understand
a lot of people say i don't understand
why she's with me yeah this is like
you're like donald trump
yeah yeah we don't get why people are
voting for you
[Laughter]
we just don't understand what's
happening yeah yeah
i don't even know and you're the dumb
public that's like we like donald
trump
yeah i think actually that's the perfect
way to explain it because i don't even
think the dumb public
knows exactly what they love about him
they can't they can't
what they hate about everyone else is
what the problem is yeah you being with
bobby
says one every guy you've been with
before you have
horrible taste in men like they must be
monsters okay you must have been with
like
you know what it is satan and then
you're just like oh they were
finally somebody with horrible feet
that's all
this is like yeah if bobby's like a
blessing
man and i'm telling you now he is
only because people everybody else that
i've dated in the past were just
so [ __ ] textbook perfect
and boring it's like you and those girls
that were kidnapped for 10 years in
cleveland
the only ones that would
they come they come back from being
kidnapped bobby
i like here's my prince charming i like
a little bit of unpredictability in my
life and i like good stories to tell
and and in my life and i've been in long
relationships with very normal people in
the past and i just always found myself
bored out of my mind by myself like self
entertaining
i i i question that i need to see a
dossier of like
your previous boyfriend no she she dated
a math teacher
no she the last guy she dated before me
was a spanish professional soccer player
he's on facebook from la liga she's he's
on fifa have you played with him before
no i would never okay so you thought you
wanted to be with somebody that wouldn't
cheat on you then
exactly or someone because he was
cheating on you or probably listen if
he's a professional talking player he
was getting a lot of [ __ ]
you know what that wasn't something that
i did you even care
also he lived in spain yeah i mean it's
not like really really was getting a lot
of
keep reminding her how much [ __ ] he was
getting a lot of [ __ ]
i'm not unrealistic i mean i was kind of
it was
it was a relationship that lasted for a
year and a half that was sort of open so
sort of not but those guys are very like
machismo so they don't want you to hook
up with other people and then when i
[ __ ] started dating here they were he
went free he went crazy yeah
well yeah he goes is he the guy from
hangover
he couldn't understand he really sent
that my message what
you really thought he thought he said
kala you are losing your mind
i think you need to like enter a mental
institution because imagine
you don't know who i am at all yeah
you're leaving
you're in a different country and then
you just see a photo yeah
of a small fat disgusting looking asian
dude
you can there's probably six more things
you could say
so really but i totally get it yeah yeah
cause he's like a professional athlete
body looks probably like
delicious you know what i mean yeah yeah
delicious
probably yeah he can't believe it and he
saw a photo of me just don't
tell you something this is the only
reason why she did that like at first
she didn't really like you
she just wanted to the biggest [ __ ] you
to him ever is let me let me find the
most disgusting
and then what happened was she was like
yeah i see something right now
she was like because i really like you
[ __ ] you literally looked at yourself
you grew on her in the [ __ ] mirror
like i was like the [ __ ] human you
grew on her this was great you look like
somebody drew you
i mean look at your face look how
offended he got
look at this he's the ugliest black dude
i've ever seen
anyway let's move on i like you thanks
for doing the podcast i appreciate it
i'm just saying doing the podcast can
you just admit to him that that was
ask her why she's dating me we just did
i just answered all the answers
questions we know why she wanted to give
back at her professional absolute
boyfriend
because you grew on her like the mold on
your foot yes her shallowness was like
you know what
she said to herself you know what i'm i
don't need attractive anymore
yeah i don't need tall i don't need
anybody that can protect me in an
alley i don't need anybody that can get
things off the top shelf
you know yeah i don't need anyone that
knows how to use a toilet properly or
have you know i just say
i've i had surgery four days ago and not
once
has he so much has taken care of me for
an hour
he's the person i'm going to say this
right now and that's
so first of all i come home right and
there's
her mom her sister i have a good family
her ex
guy that she used to see but her best
friend it's my best friend up
like that jessica your best friend okay
you know that oh that's connected to
your best friend you know that ugly you
know that ugly ass korean girl you just
saw earlier
she wasn't that ugly come on moon face
you saw moon face i saw her she was here
i'm trying to eat her butt i'm trying to
eat her butt
yeah it's an experiment for them yeah
he's never eaten and so it's like
they're like
they're all spending the night which is
weird right eric so i slept there
you slept there yeah also our whole
family is here
what i don't mean if you you've dated a
filipina you know just that we come in
it's yeah it's a lot of fun ridiculous
and so we were all spread out in the
room they were all taking care of me so
you know how it goes eric
steve's i got steve's moving in right
now so you're saying
steve needs to live here but i think he
likes to live like a communist
no no no no steve's a survivor he's like
a roach you could pick him up and put
him anywhere
and he'll set up base camp that's just
how he is yeah yeah he's
never ready for the zombie apocalypse my
brother's a lot like my dad
my dad had a st we lived in san diego
and he had a store
in sacramento right so he would drive
every other week to sacramento and just
stay a week
what kind of store we own clothing
stores back in the 80s
really what kind of clothes it's fashion
for women
it was called fashion gal fashion is it
plus size
fashion i love it
did you have to work at the store i did
sometimes yeah oh my god
really my dad and my uncle's own 75 at
one point wow
they were doing really good what the
[ __ ] so what happened to all that family
money bankrupt
but so my brother and i one day go we go
during the summer we go
dad we're gonna drive up there with you
because he's been for years he was
driving up there every other week
turned out it was a swap meet i'm not
kidding you right now dude we went to
this apartment where he lived
right no furniture not
anything a little like korean mat
no blanket right and a little like one
of those
plug-in stoves that's all that was in
there that's how it was looking so he
had the electricity
on yeah he had the electricity on it but
like it was just like a
wood stove in retrospect that's what my
brother is
my brother's yeah my mom is the fancy
one
that's where i take like she goes we
make gazebo this summer so she made a
gazebo like she hired somebody
yeah we got a koi fish farm like she
loves [ __ ] like that that's why your dad
needed a place that was just like
you know you're mom free you know just
like a yeah i don't want to know
yeah no furniture you know what i mean
but what did my dad because back then my
dad didn't
he didn't he doesn't watch tv he's not
he's never seen a tv show has he seen
you on tv
yeah he's been on tv oh oh yeah he was
on matt tv a bunch of times yeah
he was getting residual checks she had a
center for aphra
the union he's sad you're dead yeah yeah
he was [ __ ]
that's how much we had him on but my dad
doesn't like music
wow he did he go name a beatles song i
don't know
i mean who who's bob dylan i don't know
he doesn't know anything you say who's
tom hanks i don't know
he does he doesn't know what a movie is
he probably didn't even know what he was
doing
so what i'm saying is that what the [ __ ]
was he doing
every night by himself in a mat
in a like an apartment with no furniture
well he was [ __ ] jacking off
like you think so but it's just so sad
to think about that
no he needed i totally get it he had
these crazy kids yeah but back then
they're
sure you guys were insane when you were
young because yeah his wife was spending
all his money
yeah you're right maybe that was it and
then he just needed to go i find it like
a
like a man cave you know he also could
have had
things that we don't not even aware of
probably has another family
oh my god what would you do if you found
out you had brothers and sisters
half brothers and sisters well all
koreans look the same anyway so this
could be possible
[Laughter]
what you look the same
look at that look are you getting that
on camera yeah he's got it on camera
he's got racism on camera
oh it's loud racism cam
we don't you know that's if only people
can hear your ass
before the cameras start rolling really
at least i'm real with my thing
my friend let me say something right now
with stereotypes
you know that stereotype asian people
look alike yeah do we yes
[Laughter]
but do it i mean you know for sure no
like
so what i'm saying all right well all
right dude so
have you been to the airport walked by
an asian guy is that bobby you thought
that one time
are you being real i was like i woke up
behind a dude and i was like bobby oh
[ __ ]
oh really and it was like a little
grandma
[Laughter]
same body shape yeah no you know all
but i'm saying there's a similarities
there is similar obviously that's how
you can go
wait first of all could you pick a
korean out of a a bunch of people
what do you mean like if you saw like a
group of people you could go oh that
person's korean yeah yeah you know why
why
because there's distinct looking things
that are distinctly korean
that's why you can go oh that guy's
korean yeah but i could also go
that's sally the korean that's kathy the
korean
sometimes no all the time [ __ ] not what
they're all dressed the same at an
audition
still all right like i've never looked
at stephen newton and went
steve i mean my brother steve you know
or i never looked at daniel day kim ago
is that
sung kang sometimes yeah
but definitely you don't look any like
any any black person i've ever met
understand i don't care
yeah or like i wrote a long-ass email
about it do you fight tsa
the way he does well i have don't you
get tsa pre
i don't have that oh you could that's
because you're talking about the same
airline okay i'm gonna do that
just go to like you you you need to get
the globe yeah
told me how to treat tsa he fights
everything and i fight them every time
and i just disassociate when we're in
the airport i go into a completely
separate line because i don't even want
to pretend like i'll tell you why
here we go you're not a police officer
uh yeah don't get me started
okay and i'm going to say this all right
this question
you'll be like putting your stuff on
that little you know i mean belt thing
right and they'll go some some stranger
will go
where are you going sir and i don't
answer them
this is none of your [ __ ] business i
know you already saw my [ __ ]
yeah i'm not answering you all the [ __ ]
i had to go through to get to this point
yeah you know i don't oh i hate him i
i was at uh chicago and like so
the for some reason the line was a
little messed up so they had
and then this lady was yelling at us you
know she was like you know yeah
just going on and on and i was like um
this is a customer service business okay
like and then there was luckily there
was this white guy there in a suit
and he was like i need to see this
jake's manager so the manager comes over
and her name was cookie of course oh wow
like the show and she was just acting up
and i said to the guy
i said let's not act like this is the
first time you've got a complaint about
her attitude
okay and then you know he was just like
trying not to be like it's like come on
like
like learn some cuss manners you know
like
i i feel like that's not a government
assigned job
okay you actually filled out an
application and was like i want to do
this job
it's like dude it's like they have one
application for the post office
dmv parking enforcement and tsa and then
they just assign them because they all
have the same i know
ridiculous another thing though it's not
really their fault
right it's like they probably are told
all these things
about rules and you know i mean how to
look for you know i mean
isis you know i mean and all these
things a million people go through the
airport
how many times do you think they'd stop
a terrorist
what how many times do you think they
stop a terrorist at lax
exactly no because that [ __ ] would be on
the news we found a terrorist no
never has happened out of 10 million
people there's probably
one person that this is also a dog so
that's not the route
they're gonna take the next time because
when they did 911 was such a [ __ ]
shock because no one had
really done that before to steal our
planes and use our planes against us
which
i've said this before was a [ __ ]
genius
yeah idea but not wrong and evil but not
in the worst thing ever
but not in the long run it's not like
like if you're isis let me tell you
if isis this would be the stupidest
thing ever if isis
did get a bomb and blew up some city or
anything like that
all they would do is poke the bear and
then it would be
the only reason why we don't go over
there and just ransack the place as it
is is because we police ourselves
you know we got the we got people going
no we don't want any kids to die
we don't want any families to die we
don't want any soldiers to die
if they killed hundreds of thousands of
people all that would mean it would just
be this should be over like this because
we would be like it would be like
hiroshima nagasaki yeah we don't [ __ ]
around
we don't [ __ ] around when it comes to oh
no we didn't we
what we did after 9 11. it wasn't enough
let's just i'm just saying
what we did after 9 11 the response had
made no absolute sense we took out
and we police ourselves so what you're
wait i'm not getting what you're saying
so what you're saying right now is is
that
if there was even a big like they killed
a hundred thousand people
then what you're saying that our
response would be devastating to them
yes i don't think so no because we would
have the we would have the okay
because even that responsibility but
here's the thing though we had the okay
to go into afghanistan to find osama bin
laden right
because that's what happened he
was in charge of 9 11 right instead
we went into a country right and then we
we took out
sudan hussein who had nothing to do with
9 11. so what i'm saying is is that
regardless of what they do to us our
response
is probably going to be created they're
not going to make any [ __ ] sense
look what this is this is about about
homeland security i'm more
conservative than i am liberal because i
liken it to like if we're playing
basketball
on the yard and getting serious yeah
there's always a guy that's like
man [ __ ] y'all i'm gonna go to my trunk
you know and back in the hood that just
means this guy's got a gun in his trunk
right
okay now the difference between a
liberal and a conservative
the liberal is gonna let him get to the
trunk and kill three people
and then do something about it the
conservative is gonna be like
uh you're not getting to the trunk we're
gonna beat your ass right here
now check this out there may not be a
gun in the trunk
right but the action was taken yeah
that's the difference between the two
no so the conservative the conservative
would go to
somebody that had nothing to do with the
situation and beat the [ __ ] out of them
that's what we did so same was the gun
the reason why we have isis in the first
place is because we destab stabilize
that region
there was a civil war we needed to be
destabilized really to create isis
look that's just a byproduct of yeah and
the worst byproduct that we can imagine
lobby yeah we we've been over to that
place yeah we've been over to these
places we have
they don't know how to treat their own
people they're [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
ridiculous like
egypt should be [ __ ] bulldozed okay
like it's like
they don't follow traffic laws
they don't follow traffic laws goats get
out of [ __ ] buses in the middle of
the freeway yeah
careful erica
like some of these places all the oil
money is going to like one family
they're not they're not helping their
own people
yeah like that [ __ ] is the thing that
creates and the oil money is being
funded they fund right these terrorist
activities
my point is that everyone's including
just our fault
just listen everyone's in cahoots right
and i believe right
that if we were attacked our response
wouldn't be not my point i'm trying to
make to you is this
but just trying to convince me no no if
we were attacked there would be no
we would it would galvanize everybody
like it did after 9 11.
i remember what what we did was we did
something that had nothing to do
it doesn't matter the [ __ ] action it
doesn't matter but but that was still
the mandate was given go do something
what you're saying is what they did
wasn't proper okay i'm telling you
though all right so before that all
right so
the country was like so do something so
if isis attacks us right we will do
something and we'll attack china
because it's right now we probably need
to because china
no you know what you need to get china
because china and north korea are still
not there
nothing to do with that they're still
missing the point i'm not missing any
points what i'm
saying i'm telling you if something bad
happens the whole country's gonna be
like all right we're okay with you doing
whatever
like i mean look at what happened in
like in [ __ ] the last drop a bomb on
iran
belgium did they catch everyone from
belgium yet i think they did the
brothers
yeah yeah but where paris like all these
things
when they can't when when [ __ ] like that
happens those people always end up dead
the first time i've ever seen somebody
not end up dead is that guy from the
boston
marathon oh yeah um usually the cops
the government you know what i call them
they don't [ __ ] around with pewdiepie
they just don't [ __ ] around with things
like that i know he's evil
and this is what [ __ ] right because
remember rolling stones put them on the
cover of the [ __ ] magazine women
write him and
and you know he has women followers and
how dare you make him look like a rock
star
how dare you make him look like a rock
star sex with jesus
i'm going to just say this he's a
[ __ ] evil little [ __ ]
and he deserves to die he's cute
tsarnaev and that's a fact
which one though that's a fact georgie
do you think he's cute you're talking
about the younger one sarnath
the one that's alive but that's not
supporting him saying that
yeah i'm not saying anything i'm just
that's how people are to misconstrue
that
if he wasn't a terrorist that suck his
dick bobby thinks the guy's cute
you know it means that he's okay with
terrorism that's how people do it yeah
yeah usually those people end up dead
you know when you hear about a shooter
or something yeah right the next day
it's like what
the the guy the shooter dies in the
every time yeah
columbine am i gonna get trouble for
saying that just now that tsarnaev is
cute no he has a face
that was such a stick if he wasn't a
terrorist this happens all the time
why are you talking like that hey man
bro i'm singing a song in the beginning
you don't interrupt me until i [ __ ]
introduce you man
we got kalila my beautiful kalila
my beautiful [ __ ] island queen from
the mud rivers
of the philippines we've got uh does the
philippines have mud rivers we got
two-dimensional face
gilbert can't see me if he goes to the
side he disappears
we have right here richard ramirez he's
out he's back night soccer is back
yeah knight stalker actually don't like
how he's in the closet
i know and we got uh he's accomplished
there's a girl in here that's like
yeah i accomplished george kimon that's
how you pronounce it and um we got um
a very special cause we've had him
before this i think this is the first
time we've used no we've used assa a
couple of times
but this is his um fat lando
from i'm not going to go there there's a
new movie called you already
had star wars and he's scotland and um
you're fat yoda [ __ ] that's who you are
oh yeah you can't even get all those
skyrockets back new skywalker's like
yoda i don't know if i can how about we
walk together bro
it's good it's good it's good i asked
for it i asked for it
yeah um so we got eric griffin back and
um
he's on a new television program called
i'm dying up here
and it's on show time and uh and my
special comes out july 7. well we're
going to do that [ __ ] dude
i'm sorry but i don't know don't you
load it's so unorganized and i'm not
sure
that's the thing in the chaos
and um when i get my beard
transplant which is what i'm going to do
i'm going to use i told you i'm going to
use your knuckle hairs
i mean what the [ __ ]
you're gonna do that's that's what's up
let me let me find any mustache you have
on your face
are you gonna talk about this let me
finish
this right
no this is like right before the in a
werewolf movie right before the guy goes
rotten you know yeah you don't want to
shave that [ __ ]
or wax it i've tried then it turns into
your butthole
yeah yeah yeah oh my god that's so weird
i just noticed that yeah it's really bad
because you're such a big guy that
there's just so much to look at here we
go
so i just i slowly noticed first of all
bobby per capita you're way fatter you
know what i mean
[Laughter]
yeah a water hose is going to come out
next
but over time she'll know which uh which
battles to
you know you got to pick and choose your
battles wait how many [ __ ] battles
she could pick with me but the video
game thing you don't how
how long has it been since you've heard
anything about the video game because he
doesn't play them anymore yes he does
all day
not the good ones not with you
[Laughter]
you got to play in donkey kong and [ __ ]
in here if okay
do you scream like him when he plays yes
no you don't oh my god
baby he screams louder than me yes i'm
yelling we're having a great time
i know you know how much we miss bobby
but you know what to your criticism
he is a better human being i can tell
he's like more fun
i can't play destiny with you because
i'll tell you why okay
i i i gain resentment
deep resentment i gain um
i i start like kids all you know what
because there's kids i play with yeah
yeah on destiny them yelling at me and
telling me what to do oh yeah i know it
was like literally kind of going what
the [ __ ] am i doing bobby remember when
we started playing it was just you and i
and we were like oh we got to get
somebody else so we got steve in yeah
and then we got like oh
that's when craig came in we started to
get all these people but once we started
expanding into like people we don't know
i'm right there with you yeah but here's
the thing but you guys
suck yeah but it's not about
we do we do something when did you ever
win anything
yeah yeah yeah yeah this one really yeah
i had to hear the painful crying
suffering i know
but the fun of it was of losing all day
because we were playing together yeah it
was the camaraderie of it
but here's the six a.m in the morning we
played for seven hours
ever been to the lighthouse no i'm never
going to
right why what do you want to live like
that i
listen i totally understand what you're
saying i i know i get as equally as
frustrated with this
[ __ ] game i'm playing and i'm like
we're doing like trials or some [ __ ]
yeah
and i'm like and i'm like i hate this
i'm not having fun like i'm literally
not having fun because there's no way to
get better at it like i don't care like
i change
controllers different guns why would you
want to because i like playing with you
guys
that's what it's all about yeah bobby
don't you remember we
became friends because we were in the
middle east playing xbox
on the road that is true can you guys
find a different interactive game
other than destiny screaming we were
gonna do a podcast together
i see that i see that
that's what we were gonna do until it's
yoko ono
but i'm not bitter i remember we
went to all things comedy together i
know we even had a meeting oh i'm sorry
yeah i was in the car when you made the
phone call and i told you to go to that
meeting and you didn't the second time
around
whatever yeah anyway it was done who
want the mics once that is done
wait eric when was like when did you buy
a mic oh see
listen okay hey baby baby baby you are
the best thing to happen to this guy
there you go i recognize that there you
go
him and i this room you think this room
would look like this it would be crazy
in here
we wouldn't be doing the parking lot i
still think that you guys should do a
podcast together and i've
always said it but i don't want your
[ __ ] pity podcast
yeah i don't know what you mean the
sylvia plath references and all this
stuff
[Laughter]
listen to me man listen but you know
what at the end by
eric at the end of the day right like
you know when i first met you
i'm like who the [ __ ] is this piece of
[ __ ] and i saw you perform in the middle
east we went to the middle east
sebastian and i'm ed and the single tear
came down your uh your cheek
yeah there was no porn and he couldn't
make the crowd laugh
oh no i'm just teasing he was killing
you know how he is i thought he was he
never thinks he can do well
but anyway um i saw you that
years ago it was 10 years ago and i saw
you go up and i was like
this [ __ ] guy is really good you know
and we've been friends since then um
i'm really just blessed to have you in
my life and we're you're invited to all
of our life
events should we have whatever should we
have one so she's gonna
be everywhere huh and congratulations
and congratulations
you have with uh paulie shore
congratulations on that a new project
you are so full of [ __ ] oh never mind i
hate you
yeah he's doing he's gonna do a youtube
video with paul paulie has come up to me
three times
i know i did it i know but he's come up
to me three times as if we haven't had
the conversation already i know
because he's afraid he's afraid that he
can't get you no he called me on the
called me yeah all right first of all i
was in a parking lot and he he like
was trying to act like he was mad about
him dying up here yeah he was like you
know
and i said paulie you're not this good
of an actor yeah
yeah yeah i know you like this show stop
yeah so he told me about the thing then
he emailed me i said oh it's great did i
do it i hit up bobby i was like bobby
tell me about this thing and he goes you
have to do it
it you politically have i know you have
to do it but i i i still think it's
funny
with all the people that are more isn't
it it's good do you do what he does
played a political game
no not as not like he does it you know
what i mean this guy's south korea over
here
i know but um i see paulie at the spa
and i'm literally getting to the point
where it's like if i see him i'm going
to avoid him
but he like because he says chinese
people
in in a song so i walk in and goes
chinese people are the wonderful people
in the world
and there's all these koreans
uncomfortable and then he'll walk up to
a korean man
he doesn't know and slap him in the ass
why would he slap him in there it's
[ __ ] crazy
and i go you're gonna get in trouble
because i now did but in korea they'd
kill me but here
we're in america dude like what the [ __ ]
he called me one time this is like a
couple years ago to go to the gorn
ramsay uh
iron chef or whatever that thing that he
does okay yeah so we're sitting in like
we're just we're eating food you know
yeah and um paulie's getting his food
yeah and he goes over to gordon ramsay
he's not supposed to do this yeah yeah
and he's like gordy no
gordy yeah yeah this isn't cooked right
you know i was like
then the camera comes over to us and i
look at the camera and i go you invited
paulie shore like
you thought he was going to sit down and
have a pleasant meal yeah like come on
man
this is something can i tell you the
most embarrassing thing i ever saw him
do what's that
we're in san diego and we're at jamba
juice this is the only this is when
juice like there was only jamba juice
yeah they didn't have all the fancy
fancy good [ __ ] now right but now it was
jamba juice so
there was a line out the door and he
just
cuts to the front right and paulie
shouted and he cuts
and they [ __ ] served them and i
waited in the line
actually anyone can do that what
listen i it's all about attitude i'm
going to say this right now
you know what i want to say this right
now okay you literally
oh here we go black version of me all
right oh no not at all yeah
you don't look like chris spencer so
we're funny
that's how angry funny angry
funny and charming what yeah yeah bobby
i know what i'm working with
yeah you do right okay and i know what
i'm working with and we're the same
no not really why we pull both we both
played the video games
like [ __ ] 12 year olds but i'm tall
you can reach things on the higher you
you're shocked you're fat
yeah but that can change that you
haven't but i can
but i did three years ago i had a
trainer
i know but i can but here's the thing
exactly i can always go back
you're always going to be here like a
hair like a pear
why are you so mad i don't know why i'm
so angry right now but the thing is is
that um
you're welcome i know but i also want to
say waiting there she is she's sitting
next to you this is how i met eric
griffin how i got to know him how long
ago okay
so um ahmed i met our friend
our good friend our men said hey do you
want to play the middle east
with you eric griffin and sebastian
monoskalco
oh and i said um you just farted yeah
this is this is what i'm saying okay
and keep it in my body well you keep
everything else in that body
your body's like a clutch purse
it holds all the necessities yeah so we
play the middle east now i don't know
who
he is you know i i mean i had met him
once before i did oh tell him
what how i acted during this is so
embarrassing remember that one show
where i'm at no no no okay first time
we've ever met yeah yeah you're gonna
set this up okay
and i would you want to say this right i
don't know i almost was i almost killed
you was i mad tv at the time
but i don't even remember but you were
the biggest dick okay just tell them
when i said crazy
so first of all he comes to this show we
had this great show out in uh
newport beach we were playing we were
paying comics in the city
a thousand dollars to come do a show he
comes and he's a nightmare
from the beginning to the end like just
the biggest
diva i've ever [ __ ] met what did i do
you were just doing all kinds of [ __ ]
you were like you know it was like
get my car and um yeah yeah
he was just like complaining the whole
time about the show these people hate me
these people i don't want to be here
this is ridiculous how dare you he was
like how dare i met a man
booked me in this [ __ ] he was going on
and on about the show
just the biggest worst diva ever you
know i had to call a man like a man you
need to come down here because i'm about
to kill bobby lee
he did not like me no i just was the
worst but i didn't know who he was
you know i was like i didn't get it yeah
i thought he was the guy from digital
ownership you actually thought that yeah
this ugly guy
you know he's the glasses and you know
the
glasses in the nose that they have i
thought he was wearing one of those
things
you know that's a little thing that they
do at that thing so what were you guys
conversations do you guys even talk
no he was like come on man don't act
like that i'm like [ __ ] you man
i wasn't [ __ ] i was [ __ ] crazy
yeah he was crazy oh i was [ __ ] crazy
were you sober
yeah i'm sober yeah whoa god you just
have diva tendencies he still has diva
oh god don't even get me started what
you you don't you know what i hate about
you to this day yeah it's like you don't
communicate properly
no he like i have to text you a thousand
[ __ ] times for you to get back to me
you never answer your phone your [ __ ]
voicemail is always full
you know how how does your do you have
another phone do you know how people get
in contact how have to call you yes
your the manager and agent have to call
you hey can you tell bobby that's
ridiculous
al and bill burr are having him are
having him on a podcast on wednesday
they didn't contact him they can't have
contacted me
anything that any he had anytime he has
to be anywhere it's through me
because he will not reply let me ask you
a question
have you ever heard of ronan
look at me right now right now i'm
asking you a question have you ever you
are not
ronin okay
have you heard of ronin you do ronan's
dry cleaning at best
okay you know what a ronin is right a
masterless samurai
all right so what i am is i'm wandering
through these dirt
listen in japan i have a sword and i'm
scratching my back
and i'm walking through these dirt like
pathways and i'm just
a wandering samurai just longing for a
home
okay and that's what i am you have
friends
okay that want to be in your life
and you are interact and you are my but
it frustrates me when your ass don't
call back
i hate that that's fine because the
things that you want
i know what you want no you don't yeah
you do no you don't get back on destiny
there's a new dlc coming out i will
defend him
because i see your messages pop up oh
i'm playing fallout right
and you get this right yeah because i'm
at home going like you're gonna end so
he repeatedly does it a thousand times
until i answer
right so i know what you're that's all
right so we're in the middle east
go on okay so then we i did that right
and then so i go to the middle east
and i with sebastian who's a dear friend
and i literally just
we i saw eric griffin perform very for
the very first time
on stage and i literally watched them
and i said
this is years ago like a decade ago
right no that's not that long ago it was
like five or six years ago
no it's far longer it's not because i
started in 2003.
all right so five six years ago and i
saw him for the first time and i said
this guy is really legitimately funny
well and he doesn't look like some just
shut the [ __ ] up leave something out of
the story though i know we're gonna get
to that but you shut the [ __ ] up
all right all right and i literally
because he doesn't look like
that he is going to be that funny when
you see him you know man what are you
talking about this is how comedy
supposed to look
now because now i can put that ugly face
into your comedy and i'm like okay now i
get how the packaging works right
but at the time i'm like that packaging
is so awful
it's like [ __ ] it's like a it's like a
[ __ ] elephant [ __ ] and then they put
glasses on it
and they put it out you know what i mean
so it's like but now i'm like this is
because he's so mad how how i blasted
him
so i looked at sebastian i said this
guy's [ __ ] and then we
legitimately became friends we went to
bahrain
um abu dhabi we went to beirut well
there's more to the story okay bobby had
bombed so bad
that he thought it was the crowd you
know what i mean he was like wow these
people just don't get comedy yeah yeah
and then i was awful this is what you
really said to me
he didn't tell the story right
he goes up to me said when i saw you on
stage and what you did
a single tear came down my face yeah
yeah
we had a good time okay like bought a
xbox and we started playing fifa and
that was what we did we played fifa
everything this is one this happened to
me one time i was at the airport and
they had like you know how they have
different lines
yeah okay so they had this like tsa
pre-line yeah okay i'm in the tsa
pre-line now it's getting kind of long
everybody has tsa pre-now so this [ __ ]
isn't even special
but was just two old people and i saw
their tickets
yeah i knew that and they were trying to
cut and i'm looking around everybody's
got an attitude everybody's like
and i say i go okay i'm gonna be the
only one
so i you gonna put this all on me yeah
yeah yeah
i had to go excuse me you're in the
wrong place you need to move yeah you
know
it's like i hate them that's why because
people don't want to
you know what you put in your say
anything tsa a pocket [ __ ]
wait what do you know why why is that
because they don't know what it
is through the scanner so it always gets
opened up
okay and then they have to [ __ ] pull
it out okay
and who's that embarrassing for yeah who
exactly is
it's sticky because of me all right but
he has to pick it up now my question is
you should make a mold of your dick and
you should make
we have a lilac pocket [ __ ] and you
guys should sell right here
oh we have bobby's dick you have so many
like stuff
you guys should someone sent us a dick
maker dildo maker oh yeah
oh bobby that's wow you can make 10 of
bobby's
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah bobby this is as big as you this is
like your
i mean imagine yeah yeah it's light skin
tone too
yeah yeah yeah we have to dip this in
mustard
he said that on the stage the other day
what did you say that i look like bobby
looks like you know the honey bottle
yeah with the bear honey bottle yeah
yeah but it's filled with
mustard he said that in in front of a
crowd
what today i said bobby looks like if
some asian kids peed in the snow
then they made a snowman out of that
stuff but did i attack you what did i
say you always attack me you little [ __ ]
don't try to on camera right now i'm
trying to [ __ ] sing oh
wow this is what he does this is what
i've heard it so i believe you this is
what he does
he's the worst i say that you don't look
human you look like tim burton drew you
[Laughter]
every other episode we've had on tiger
belly he says something about oh my gosh
how about the billboard in times square
yeah how it's leaning
yeah but your billboard would be on a
hot dog stand because
all right it would be so little we have
a question
are you hungry are you hungry yeah let's
go eat this you want to go eat guys
yeah oh yeah yeah unhopeful advice with
bobby
kalila and eric griffin
what the [ __ ] is that it's second city
dude
that's what is that brought to you by
stamps.com
hey tiger belly fam i'm curious about
what you think about cultural
appropriation and how people say it's a
form of racism
i see social justice war